et on verra il viendra quand il sera
calme asos d'accord alors on a on a on
amuse arrière qui a refusé de chanter
place des groupes déguisés en patrick
bruel
j'vous le dis et j'ai décidé donc de
prendre un nouveau vigiles voit la mort
avec moi qui va me protéger j'ai pris
quelques uns d'un coup plus costaud de
mokhtar te prends ta jour propose
d'accueillir celui qui va remplacer
mokhtar il s'appelle léonard
applaudissements polis
[Applaudissements]
cela
voilà
merci c'est bien merci voilà comme ça
lui il est là et lui fait tout les
happenings que je veux mais cyril on
vous a dit qu'il n'était pas vivant que
c'était pour de faux il abat chanter un
ennemi inquiétez pas il fera ce qu'on
lui dira si par exemple je me lève et
j'ai envie de te mettre ne tape pas
qu'est ce qu'il va faire lui essaye tu
verras ce que vous allez on prend l'une
bêtement on va parler du dos du jour
c'est mon partenaire particulier est ce
que c'est le dating qui va trop loin
c'est ce soir à 21h sur m6 ils
diffuseront donc un nouveau programme
intitulé mon parti